Jeffrey finally you have cracked the
code after seven draws you finally get a
victory there was so much pressure on
you Anastasia took you as her pick to
win the tournament you felt the pressure
on your shoulders
well no but you know that you tell me
this I feel it a little bit
and how does uh that feel to finally get
a victory especially with the black
pieces
yeah I'm
okay uh I guess it ruined my chance at
13 draws but yeah it felt it feels good
to to break through for sure especially
um it seemed like we're heading towards
the same direction in the game he went
for
pretty safe approach with by the way did
you anticipate the fantasy variation no
no I don't think he's ever played it but
luckily I played it myself for white so
I knew some things and queen takes D4
comedy by surprise because usually
um the movie was night before and yeah
there's some Sharp
uh continuation here after Knight F6
I think it's like E5 Knight G4
E6 yeah Bishop V6 Bishop C4 and I think
it's a drop so he probably wanted to get
a game with Queen D4 but
there I thought
still seemed reasonable yeah Bishop B6
but wasn't it a bit strange that he
played this move F3 and was still
spending some time up to this point yeah
I wasn't sure what what exactly
if whether he's recalling or he's sort
of
bluffing a little bit like maybe he has
some really nice ideas and wants to
pretend like he doesn't know the
position so yeah I just thought okay
Bishop B6 just to get out of his prep
because I knew Bishop V6 for sure cannot
be
uh like a main move and then yeah here I
think it's just equal so 97 was maybe a
clever
um way just to get Knight G6 with the
tempo and I think the key in the
position is to control the E5 Square so
it made a lot of sense to me
um
so yeah Bishop D6 I think he wanted to
force this
end game that we got where he at least
jumps Knight F5 do you feel like he was
trying to pull the brakes at this point
already yeah I think so because
otherwise if I I mean if I get my
blockade on E5 it's very pleasant so
Knight F5 it seemed correct
and I think the critical moment uh if we
just keep going down
yeah rocket [ __ ] was a good I think it's
a good try to fight for the atrial
but the key I think is uh okay H4 is
fine and by the way it does seem like
right now the engines are recommending
black as the favorite yeah yeah I I
slightly prefer black but I think his
main mistake was trading Rooks why do
you prefer black because it does look
like okay he has the bishop he has more
space on the king side why do you prefer
I think it's due to my really nice
Knight on E5 and the pawn on F5 is
overextended a little bit so I can sort
of Target that in the future so the pawn
uh our launch maybe is working against
him on the king side yeah
H6 Knight to E4 and U.S 96 but here I
thought F6 immediately was maybe a
better solution if you wanted to play F6
uh because yeah now he gets goes Rook H6
and I don't think I can take and the key
is actually on H6 or yeah I don't think
I can take on H6
um because yeah he will get H7 a G5 so
rookies H1 H7 and Knight to G5 well at
least it wasn't clear how how I win the
pawn so yeah the point is actually very
important that if I take on D1 after F6
he can take with the bishop yeah instead
of G6
he takes with the bishop to avoid the to
avoid the uh yeah so now if you take
take on G7 that's winning and if you go
well if you cannot go to six yeah so
then yeah but in general FG should be
just dropped closer yeah it should be
wrong got it so this was the way for him
to probably put the brakes
um completely at this point because yeah
now I Think It's Tricky for him right
and he played this move C4 this
completely shocked us yeah
uh I was wondering what is his idea and
then I think I figured it out he was
maybe for whatever reason assuming that
I would throw in Rook H2
because it looks nice and then at least
here he has rookie one okay and maybe
now I can't take the pawn because if
they take a knight C5 yeah
then the rule comes to you at least yeah
here he has play so I don't know what it
what it was exactly but he maybe forgot
I could just take uh immediately
immediately with the rook and then the
Rook comes to E8 perhaps this is what he
missed yeah but I think I mean you you
stopped calculating though if you see
this I mean I have more uh
like I have other options I can play
Knight B6 as well
here yeah so for sure I I think he just
uh
yeah it's hard to say maybe you just
forgot I could take immediately
Wesley uh Wesley
congratulations a big victory for you uh
how are you feeling about your chances
with Fabiano right now surging through
the rankings Rey also winning game after
game what do you need to do to win this
event yeah Fabian Ray I I think they're
just playing amazingly if they continue
there's not much I can do so
yeah I have a very tough schedule coming
up so I'll just do my best
guys yeah quick question for you Jeffrey
first of all our congratulations of
course and as a Karo Khan player I I had
some awkward experiences against the
fantasy variation and you chose a
defense Queen B6 that I've never used
I've used G6 in my practice uh G6 I've
taken taken E5 Knight F3 and Bishop E6
again these are ways I've met the
fantasy variation you chose Queen B6 how
did you come up with this I mean it's
it's an unusual approach for me how did
you come up with Queen B6 yeah it was
actually a long time ago I think when I
first picked up the caracon back in 2012
I want to say this is the line my coach
taught me so I actually I sort of kept
it I mean I I dabbled with other moves
like you said D4 E5 and and G6 I played
for both of colors but I felt like yeah
Queen B6
I don't know it gave gave me good like
most of the variations seem to be uh
quite playable so yeah yeah good who was
the coach who recommended Queen B6
[Laughter]
his name is Gabor for he's from Hungary
very very nice Queen B6 now I'm gonna
have to go research it but
congratulations Jeffrey thank you yeah I
have a question to Jeffrey I mean I
think he's a professional chess player
right now and I was wondering what are
the advantages to be a professional
chess players these days or advantages
and disadvantages if you have some ideas
yeah well there are definitely a lot of
advantages and disadvantages for me
personally I think I I value the online
opportunities a lot nowadays
um so you don't necessarily have to just
travel 24 7 essentially and make a
living now with the online tournaments
it's very very flexible so I'm not happy
about that
and disadvantages if you have any
just to know what are the downsides
affecting D5
yeah
they're they're let's just let's just
say uh there are some negative things
about being a chess player but good
price fund I mean you still have a good
price money these are I think advantages
right that is true yes okay thank you so
much and all the best of luck absolutely
um now that we've got our